[Applause]
foreign
greetings kids welcome to another fat
man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark
Bernard
hey oh Heaven's the [__] man welcome
kids uh to uh early afternoon early
evening
edition of the show
um normally we do this late and run late
but [__] no
hell no no yeah we're and we're cursing
so grow up and deal with it
um welcome back kids we got so much to
talk about uh including
the next time we do this show which is
literally gonna be on Friday night it's
gonna be me and Mark in the same place
in that same place
is smodcast Castle Cinemas man that's
right we're doing fat man beyond live
for the first time at smodcast Castle
cinemas as part of the Ides of Mark
Festival which begins on Wednesday
as in New Jersey tell them what we're
watching Mark I will
we're watching even on Wednesday which
is the actual odds of March uh 15th at
like seven o'clock at night or something
the original Dune not the good one no
some might say not the dennyville new
one but the actual uh the one that David
Lynch did but even David Lynch is
sometimes like kind of denies yeah I
mean I've seen the the Alan Smithy cut
be like four hour just assemblage of
everything he shot I guess that's the
one that he doesn't really cop to but I
mean he still cops to the main one the
one that went out in theaters right he
does he does I I don't know how he feels
about it but he doesn't say he didn't
make it uh that's March 15th that's
Wednesday in two days that's podcast
Cinemas in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
uh me and Mark will both be there and
then afterwards we're going to talk
about it hell yeah [__] stop us
there's dark Nate's artwork the great
Nate Gonzalez did a piece for the Ides
of Mark uh so Wednesday night there we
go with Dune uh Thursday night
shit's gonna get a little fire kids
reach of Thursday is what it means to be
young my friend oh my God excellent what
a great poll Thursday night is what it
means to be young we're gonna see Ellen
aim
[__] in concert man
um as we watch Streets of Fire
the uh the uh what was the [__] name
who directed that Walter Walter Hill
Walter the great Walter Hill great
Walter Hill Diane Lane Billy Paxton
um Rick Moranis Willem Dafoe Michael
perray Amy Madigan
listen to that cast everyone in the
audience like who the [__] are all of
those people
the audience Superman's
mom's mom the Snyder verse
um and uh that is on Thursday night and
then on Friday night
we've got
Talent mark there's no reason to be
bored on Friday night because we are
going to [__] [__] City that's right
we're gonna watch Flash [__] Gordon
uh the one and only Flash Gordon we're
gonna unload the boar worms on you
[__] oh [__]
um and then after that we're doing our
very first fat man beyond live
from smartcastle tickets all available
right now at smodcastlescinemas.com look
at that art artwork I didn't understand
it and then dark Nate explained I was
like what is this Brokeback Mountain and
he said no man this is that [__] show
that everybody but you watches what is
the show it's the last of us baby
and so we'll we'll save because I've
I've thoughts about the finale I thought
about the last two episodes but we'll
save it for Friday we'll save it for us
being in person and people like this
show quite a bit right it's a massive
hit for HBO so I'm 8.2 million people
watch the finale
um and I don't even think that's
counting definitely not counting the
seven days definitely not counting HBO
Max so yeah man
um so that's that's what we're looking
at kids today of course we're going to
talk about I finally saw Ant-Man and
we'll talk about maybe a little Mando
Taco I haven't watched the second
episode but Mark certainly has and I'm
sure that uh Banff man has watched it as
well I don't know the F man was in South
by Southwest he might have been busy
bamf man get in here and say something
bamf uh I did I downloaded it on the
iPad and I watched it on the plane
how is South by Southwest Banff man was
there working with The Hollywood
Reporter
um
which would call it as you can also get
the tickets on csmod.com kids uh I was
saying it's modcastlecinemas.com but uh
will jumped in to remind me that you
could also get them at csmod.com
s-e-e-s-m-o-d.com tickets for uh fat man
beyond tickets for I think everything
probably anyway back to you how is South
Pike
um a lot of work for me so I don't know
I got some barbecue that was good it's
much better organized
uh then Sundance seemed to be that's my
review
like uh the week before
I went down there it was kind of right
before Southpaw began for the Austin
Film Society uh does the Texas film Hall
of Fame awards and uh they inducted
um friends of mine I I was the guy who
presented him and said these cats are
amazing John and Janet Pearson John
Pearson sold clerks for us he sold he
was a producer's rep back in the day uh
he wrote the the indie film Bible Spike
Mike Slackers and dikes he uh sold Spike
Lee's first film she's got to have it he
sold
Roger and me Michael Moore's first film
and of course he sold slacker which some
people go that's Richard linkler's first
film technically not he made a film
before that called you can't
you can't learn to plow by reading a
book or something like that that's me
being very nerdy deep Cuts nerdy um so
uh John was inducted as was his good
lady wife Janet Pearson who for the last
15 years up until this year
ran the South by Southwest Film Festival
she's the one that built it into the
contender that it is now where it's like
right there with Sunday it's back in the
day when she started running it was
Sundance and then down here was South by
and then she started bringing in huge
[__] movies and guests and stuff and
now it's a premier American Film
Festival just like Sundance
everything everywhere all at once
premiered there last year and uh the d d
movie this year so it's yeah it's got
Janet she was the one that started
bringing like the big premieres there
and stuff whether you like Lena Dunham
or not she's responsible for Lena
Dunham's career she brought in Tiny
Furniture and then she debuted girls
there as well
um so there's a big TV element to it
there's a big interactive element music
is still huge at South by like it was it
started as a music festival first and
then they added film and then digital
and internet and stuff like that online
but um so I went down there and inducted
those cats and also being inducted was
Jonathan Majors because he's from Texas
um and that was like the night that
Creed opened Creed Three
um so I followed Kang on stage man
foreign he
was abducted Margo Martindale was
inducted nice yeah she was just in
cocaine bear I guess
and um Mike DeLuca you know the
executive who used to run new line
forever he was the guy responsible for
like Austin Powers getting made as well
as
a gazillion really good movies Boogie
Nights and stuff but now he runs I think
he's Warner Brothers right or yeah
pretty high up at one Warner Brothers
film
so uh he was
um I'm hitting me some [__] lavender
kids still haven't smoked weed tomorrow
is seven weeks without smoking weed
um
that's why the show's starting at three
o'clock
nothing to do got no we just might as
well do a [__] show
um on time no less uh but uh
who uh it was a pretty cool ceremony but
that was I was there right before South
by began so JC was out there working for
The Hollywood Reporter and stuff and uh
he shot with uh DND cast right dungeon
dragons so did you have
Chris Pine there Chris Pine was there he
did the entire interview as a joke
like he just made
they were like how did you feel about
your costume and he just made up a story
about his costume that wasn't real but
he did it for like four minutes deadpan
wow look at him Michelle
him uh Michelle Rodriguez was my
favorite though in like she showed up
and I had shot some stuff with her
before
but she showed up with like no hair and
makeup in like
like a wife beater and a puffy vest and
like yoga pants and she hadn't wrote
shaved her a lot oh I don't think we're
allowed to call them wife beaters wife
beaters I think we're back on them tank
tops small white tank tops
uh I just came from Texas it rubbed off
on me
um yes but you came from like the
liberal Enclave of Texas let's be honest
it's still Texas uh and she hadn't
shaved her armpits
um and so but she just doesn't care like
she's so cool she just is like I am who
I am
and it doesn't matter if I'm doing press
for the biggest movie of the spring I'm
just gonna show up the way I I am I mean
I'm not throwing I'm not throwing shade
but is
is that the biggest movie of the spring
well I mean it's it's a big really I
mean John Wick four comes out a week
after that which I think is going to do
better than it but even still like she's
also got fast X coming in may let me
tell you something I went to the movies
last night uh or yesterday afternoon uh
to see Ant-Man try to take my mind up
[__] [__] and uh you know we had
[__] an hour straight of trailers the
first trailer I saw was the Nike movie
with Ben Affleck and that Ben Affleck
directed and then the next trailer was
Flash with Ben Affleck uh then the next
trailer was Oppenheimer with Matt Damon
who was also in the [__] Nike trailer
with Ben Affleck then there was a fast X
trailer then there was a D and D trailer
both had Michelle Rodriguez and is that
her name Michelle Rodriguez
like they got three actors in Hollywood
and they're in every [__] movie
that's it like it was so weird as I was
watching it going like man can't they
spread this [__] around I mean I know
Ben and Matt have to be in the one movie
and stuff because Ben directed it I mean
they don't have to but makes sense
um but Matt features pretty prominently
in the Oppenheimer trailer as well I
mean Jonathan majors has now cycled out
like his time in being the guy
everywhere seems to be over so guys
let's let these other guys take a take
an inning or two let me tell you it's
going to be tonight Today's Show is
majorly about Majors because uh we're
going to talk about
uh we'll be the last people in the world
talking about Ant-Man
and then we'll also talk about Creed 3
because I saw that and Mark you saw
Creed Three I saw Creed Three yeah man
you saw Creed Three you did
everyone is we are we're all up to date
with Creed here we are have you seen any
of uh history of the World Part Two not
yet man I almost clicked on it last
night but uh my you know [__] Oscars
was happening so I felt some sort of
responsibility as a
something somewhat of a member of the
film Community uh to pop in from time to
time but like
it's so it's just so rough watching
those shows uh not not because I'm like
no good nominee for nothing but just
like
so like when they you know bring up two
people and they're like movies are magic
you know all that [__] all that [__]
before they read the actual nominees
like just lose it all man like just let
them get up there be like the nominees
are and [__] off
but all that like you know each one
reads a paragraph about how [__]
amazing Hollywood it's got a little well
I mean I I can I can absorb that stuff
and I guess we're gonna talk about the
Oscars for a little bit the thing this
ceremony had that none of them have had
before is in program advertisement like
I don't ever remember them saying hi I'm
Melissa McCarthy and I'm you know Chloe
from from grownish I'm in the new Little
Mermaid so am I it's exciting for us to
be in the new Little Mermaid and thanks
to Disney and his 100th anniversary
we're going to show you the Little
Mermaid trailer they're standing on the
Oscar's stage doing this you know why
that one works because it is [__] ABC
and Disney but then Warner Brothers had
another thing where it's [__] like
Samuel L Jackson and somebody else
saying you know what no it's Morgan
Freeman it's Morgan Freeman it was like
Warner Brothers is great Warner Brothers
is also celebrating its 100th
anniversary let's roll a clip Montage of
Warner Brothers stuff
from the Oscar stage like I've never
seen them tossed to a commercial for a
movie studio from that stage and then it
went to other commercials
I've just never seen them sort of
mortgage out that time
to just who paid for it okay it was um
I mean again like I'm happy for all the
people that want and [__] but you know
at one point like I watched the opening
monologue which was
and then and then uh they were talking
about you know hey man the show is going
to be long because we put every category
back in this year like Wow That's mighty
nice here
um but it don't have to be that long I
mean this is my hot take the Oscars
don't have to be that [__] long
just just [__] get up there
read your read your cat read your
nominees and announce the winner and
move the [__] on less time of like a
couple famous jackasses talking about
the magic of Hollywood Hollywood's
biggest night and more time for a
[__] for one to say some [__]
like I saw the dude win for um for the
well I guess there's three of them and
who made the fat suit and the one guy
got to talk and then the lady goes to
talk and they're like Bam Bam and
they're playing her off and you know
it's like I I would be so irritated if I
was the second or third person I tell
you man I'd be jockeying for position at
that mic but they don't have to do that
if they've cut off like [__] Margot
Robbie and and and and Morgan Freeman
Morgan Freeman it's like I don't give a
[__] about this pre-written pattern [__]
just like you know you want to impress
me let them go up there and [__] fend
for themselves and [__]
you know just make [__] up off the top
of their head never mind reading this
[__]
this stuff about how great Hollywood is
ugh but um yeah that was my one take I
didn't watch the whole thing so much so
that I was asking Mark right before like
what one best picture did what did it
did anything win yeah everything
everywhere all at once was the big and
that was expected and totally deserving
it I don't know if it was films I've
ever seen I don't I don't I don't think
it was I think that that there was a lot
of consensus that tar was going to be
the big winner of the night they thought
that Caitlyn shed for sure was going to
win best actress they thought the movie
was gonna be in the best movie you know
they thought that kihu Kwan was probably
going to win best supporting actor but I
think they felt that was about it
Maybe original screenplay but it really
I am going into it they had won the SAG
Awards they had them cleaning it up I
mean Jamie Lee Curtis was a total shock
I I thought for sure that was going to
be for as much as I was invested in this
[__] believe me I wasn't like I talked
to my bookie an oddsmaker and I had it
felt like it was going to be Angela
Bassett but uh then it was Jamie Lee
Curtis that one was kind of surprising
but it wasn't surprising to see
uh uh Short Round win uh no yeah it's I
I was talking to a couple of friends
after the ceremony who were like yeah
Angela Bassett was Rob and I'm like
listen she did phenomenal work
in 15 minutes of that movie yeah but
it's not about the performance it's
about the narrative around the
performance it's about the story that
you're telling to Hollywood along the
awards Trail and that's why Q Quan won
because the guy who gave up acting the
guy who had you know was discovered as a
child and then never got a shot again
and comes back 30 years later and
delivers great stuff Jamie Lee Curtis
has a great [__] story is that I was
a horror Queen silly comedies and who
just kind of vanished and was selling
like poop yogurt for a while this was my
last [__] hurray and so now I got I'm
nominated for Knoxville that's a great
story Brendan Frazier is a great story
yeah Brandon Frazier is a great story
is a great story and Michelle yo was a
great show oh yo it's a great story yeah
you're absolutely right it's like if you
had won an Oscar before you were not
going to win an Oscar that night and so
I ain't taking anything away from Jamie
Lee Curtis who I've always loved but
like
you know
there's a pretty tight category it was
she walked away with it was was kind of
uh that was surprising to me I ain't
against it or anything but I was like
well I wouldn't have bet that I would
have lost the Oscar pool based on that
one but I knew I would have won with
everything everywhere all at once like I
saw that movie when it first the week it
came out and
is such a [__] crazy original movie
so wonderful I was happy to see that get
awarded like crazy
um but what else won
um All Quiet on the Western Front did
well and and what is and that's a German
movie somebody said it's a German World
War one movie
um based on a novel yeah I know I know
the book but I did not read in high
school but it was it was made by it was
a German film so it was enough for best
picture or best foreign film uh both
yeah both up for both yeah
that that movie had two slots and clerks
three couldn't have one
you had a great narrative man I guess
man I guess I got to go to Germany and
make a movie so I could get an American
award
I'm hitting my [__] lavender Mark
that really [__] did
start drinking this [__] you just want
us
um what else one I mean I know the song
from RR one yes not do not do
um
and uh I think we all kind of won though
because
after everything all at once won
they strategically had Harrison Ford
present the award
and kihu Kwan ran up and gave him a hug
so so there's shots all over the
Internet of him hugging Indiana Jones on
top of him hugging Harrison Ford last
night so that's that's the win
I want to see that picture
um is he is I thought maybe a short
round would pop up in in dial of Destiny
is that not a thing
nobody knows I mean in a world where
he's like you know [__] on fire after
everything everywhere all at once I
thought somebody would do the smart
thing and be like oh my God put him in
this dial of Destiny movie
and then make him the next Indiana Jones
come on just one and Oscar
he's back right so in a world where like
you know they were talking to one point
about like maybe Chris Pratt could be
the new Indiana Jones how about not how
about you make Short Round the new
Indiana Jones and let him have a whole
[__] movie that guy's got got years
mileage on that car I mean what what I
want is this Short Round Marcus Brody TV
show
Like Short Round Marcus Brodie and Salah
Marcus Brody's dead right it's all he's
young Marcus Brody it's young Salah and
it's middle-aged [__] kihu Kwan how
do you make that work he's [__] I
don't know magic but
but no because because Temple of Doom is
a prequel that comes before Raiders and
so you could you could age that dude up
it's probably not cute one it's keyhook
on remembering [__] but yeah all right
I'll take that yeah but I just I love
the because I don't think I don't think
you're gonna get a new Indiana Jones
each time soon but there's the whole
rest of that [__] cast and so like
young daughtering gay Marcus Brody and
[__] svelte badass Salah like
scouring the world for [__] that they
shouldn't put in museums
I watched that DK Daniel 01 and Chad
said they filmed Indy five before
everything everywhere all at once came
out but still once you yeah but come on
reshoots they do that like [__] you
think that was the only time they shot
that movie so in that world I would have
been like oh my god let's get a [__]
Short Round cameo in here especially
with you know it opens the trailer opens
with Salah talking
so if you really want [__] to appeal
to somebody's nostalgia
if you don't put him in there it would
be as big of a crime as never putting
Han Luke and Leia back in the same scene
while you have the chance like why would
you do it all anybody wanted man why
wouldn't you do it
uh Tom C and Chad says kihu Kwan as
Short Round returning artifacts to their
original resting place to avoid curses
assassins Guardians that's not a bad
idea right there
take it like it's Indiana Jones has died
and [__] he left everything a short
round and short rounds like I gotta put
all this [__] back
if it's [__] like you know Ocean's 11
meets Indiana Jones where it's I gotta
steal [__] from like British museums and
return it back to the places that they
just stolen from oh that's [__] dope
I've watched that
end credit scene is Shia LaBeouf sitting
there going he left it all to that kid
what about me what about Mutt and
they're like well mutt you shouldn't
have said [__] about Steven Spielberg
yeah sit down shut up Gilbert did so
wait did the Fable men's win anything
last night no
of a movie that wasn't clerk three
that's what I'll say
um that final scene in [__] Fable
men's with uh David Lynch
as John Ford it was just [__] magical
I still re-watched that scene over and
over again
I was surprised that that John Williams
didn't get the win just like sentimental
like 92 years old still working the most
nominated person in the history of the
Oscars just this is the last time guys
what won best scorer
um
I think it was I think it was All Quiet
on the Western Front what
I think so Williams
I think it was either it was like I
remember the fableman score but you're
right it's like this is come on man so
isn't this the last time he's doing or
did he do templo dial of Destiny I don't
want to get the dollar destiny
uh he did themes for dial of Destiny it
was All Quiet on the Western Front yeah
um but he did say that he was retiring
but he would come back if Steven
Spielberg asked him in the future
so it's like a soft retirement
uh composer uh Kabuki kid in chat says
composer volcker bertelman won the
Academy Award for best score at the 2023
Oscars for his musical accompaniment to
the war film remake All Quiet on the
Western Front
uh Elvis win anything no
um
I don't think so
uh watch the movie before you get
outraged Kevin says Bruce are all quiet
was a great movie I'm not outraged
I ain't outrage I got [__] lavender
right here
I can be outraged
um I am kind of outraged that uh you
know
um
I'm not outraged at all are you kidding
me you think I got any skin in this
[__] game they don't even like me in
this town we're in town for that matter
that's why I'm in Jersey
well right now I'm not but technically
yeah that's why I'm usually in Jersey
now but uh no I just felt like
in a world of narratives right where
[__] Mark was talking about like hey
it's a great story for Jamie Lee Curtis
to his great story for kiwanda it would
have been a great story for John
Williams to win yeah that's that's where
I would have put my money
um somebody said that um
uh
they showed a piece of yoga hosers in
the pre-show because of Austin Butler
because he was in yoga losers that's the
closest I've ever gotten to the [__]
Oscars shy of Ben and Matt who won for
Goodwill Hunting
and promptly forget to thank me and
Scott
um Hollywood
night I spent most of it going between
the ceremony and then watching Saturday
Night Live clips
from the Jenna Ortega episode did you
happen to see any of it I haven't seen
it now you did one uh [__] funny
sketch called like School versus school
or something like that on PBS I don't
know if it's a real show or not but the
idea is like uh teachers and their best
students face off against other schools
and um
you know for there was one school is
like from New Jersey or some [__] and
the other school was like Professor
Zander's school for gifted children it
was kind of like and they had uh Mikey
day like bald skin in [__] the yellow
cartoon wheelchair and they also had
Jenna Ortega essentially playing a
version of Rogue
um but it was pretty funny man it was a
good sketch I don't know why they didn't
just go for it and say they're X-Men why
they or you know I didn't know why I
didn't I didn't see the point and like
kind of renaming them but you knew
exactly who they were it was pretty
funny yeah satire is your friend guys
just said with the X-Men what are they
were either gonna get sued by Disney
Disney was too busy [__] promoting
the [__] out of itself all over its
Oscar cast
have you met have we mentioned it were
Disney no man
um
well congratulations to all the [__]
Oscar winners I'm sure your lives are so
much better now
um it says hello a wonderful moment when
they get up there and like thank their
parents or like you know this is for
everybody that looks like me and stuff
like that
that part up I I wish it would the Oscar
cast is just the [__] accepted
speeches
that's that's where it's emotional and
we only really care when it's emotional
that's truly man like
let them get up there and [__] tear
their hearts out rip your hearts out in
the process talking about how long it
took to get there and the dreams and
stuff on was just like you know it
thanked his wife because
you know she was like your day's coming
which I'll be honest with you like [__]
who could have seen that she must be a
magician
like seriously like if you ever would
have guessed like
you know was the guy who was in [__]
in the Temple of Doom and Goonies one
day gonna win an Oscar like years down
decades later
so his his wife is a uh what do they
call that [__] when you could see into
the future
prognosticator I was gonna use that word
but that seems a little technical isn't
there more it's not as much fun she's
not a Seer there you go see her
um what were they in the [__] the
three witches and uh
in Macbeth I mean there's witches man
you said it right there there are three
witches what they call them is it
witches Rich Williams says sober Kevin
is all loving as Stone Kev yeah we'll
see when I review Ant-Man
um yes he is Clairvoyant somebody said
Clairvoyant yeah I'll take that or an
oracle that's what I was looking for or
Oracle uh the the witches are called the
fates
diviners his wife is a an oracle a
diviner she's prescient somebody else
pointed out it's an irregular
spectacular
um Samuel Bankston said clerks three was
just depressing yeah yeah
because life is [__] depressing
you want to get yourself a bottle of
lavender buddy I love clerks three uh I
watched you know we just had last
weekend
uh clerks open all night that's what we
did at the theater on Friday night so
from like midnight till seven in the
morning
we had a full house and we watched
clerks and then clerks too and clerks
three in between each one we were
auctioning off stuff and whatnot but I
watched all three movies back to back to
back and watched everybody age
with the exception of yours truly who
actually aged a little bit backwards
that's the the you know if you lose
weight you just that's what happens you
just look younger for some reason
um so yeah I watched Silent Bob go from
old to older to younger than the two of
them uh but man what a good time we had
and then the next night we had the
premiere of a horror film called The
Forest Hills
uh directed by Scott Goldberg and uh he
had Eddie Furlong was in it so he came
out he was
um and we had and Shelley Duvall is in
it so she zoomed in
um for the Post show discussion q a and
uh
I was you know kind of Hosting but also
trying to let Scott be his own host
um but at one point Shelley Duvall like
[__] talked about she's like it was
nice to have a director who wasn't
trying to kill me and I wanted to mine
that because I should know what she's
talking about she's talking about the
bathroom that Mark's in right now The
Shining bathroom and [__] she's talking
about how like on The Shining if you've
never seen that making of The Shining
documentary
like uh
Kubrick was not kind to that woman you
know I think she was referencing that
can't imagine she was talking about
Robert Altman and Popeye that son of a
[__] bring up Altman and stuff and
somebody was like Popeye I was like well
yeah and Nashville but yes Popeye
um is the movie about the neighborhood
in Queens Forest Hills
it's not it's about it's the Forest
Hills and it's about it's a werewolf
story okay or is it that's kind of the
point of the movie
um but the uh the the post show
discussion was good she also referenced
real quickly and I wanted to follow up
on that but then they uh chucked them
all off soon
that Francis Ford Coppola wanted to do
an episode of fairy tale theater which
was a show that Shelley Duvall like
single-handedly [__] produced for
Showtime back in the day
that
um had a bunch of famous people doing
[__] fairy tales and stuff she said
Coppola wanted to Direct One just so he
could work with video because they shot
the whole thing like on video as opposed
to film
and uh I thought that was interesting
and then that topic kind of went away
but uh that's what we did at smod Castle
last weekend this week of course as
previously mentioned when we started the
show and if you didn't hear it and
you're coming in late this Wednesday
starts the Ides of Mark that's modcastle
Cinemas me and Mark Bernardin this way
me and Mark me and Mark Bernard
I'm never good at this
um are going to be at smodcast Castle
showing a mini 80s Film Festival that
starts with Dune uh the one true Dune by
David Lynch that's on Wednesday night on
Thursday night we're watching Streets of
Fire with Superman's mom Diane Lane and
then on Friday night flash lightning
bolt ah wow yeah Flash Gordon with
[__] Queen score
um and then after that we're doing our
very first fat man beyond live
from Smock housing Cinema so this ain't
the only fat man beyond you're gonna see
this week kids no and that is the first
fat man Beyond Live we've done on the
Eastern Seaboard I was I I was gonna I
yeah on the Eastern seabird we went
further east and did it in England once
we did we did one in London and we did
one in what was that Saint John was that
it the one that's up in Canada yeah up
in Canada in Nova Scotia Nova Scotia
um we also did one at the other little
smog Castle next to
um the quick stop and you zoomed in you
weren't there
but this is the first time we're doing
it together you want to go to any of
that you want to see Dune with me and
Mark and then talk about it afterwards
you want to watch Streets of Fire you
want to sing along Streets of Fire feel
it in your soul tonight is what it means
to be young you want to [__] watch
Flash Gordon or watch Us flash our
Gordons when we do [__] fat man
beyond afterwards go get tickets right
now at csmod.com horse mod
castlecinemas.com would you like to know
which movie is selling best oh I would
it's easy to tell because the two of
them are on a Wednesday and Thursday and
the one on Friday is selling best now
there could just be people like [__] I
want to see Flash Gordon on the big
screen
um but Flash Gordon's outsawing the
other two uh by by like double numbers
and [__] Batman Beyond is out selling
all of them nice
I mean I wonder if it's because and did
we talk about it last week are we
supposed to talk about it this week
um topple the fella who played hands
zarkov passed away did he he did he did
of a long time Fiddler on the Roof he
was
um yeah no he passed away from uh
Alzheimer's complications from
Alzheimer's oh man
yeah it's no [__] good way out of
this life could you imagine you're the
star of [__] Fiddler on the Roof and
you also get to play uh doctor what's
his name
you're playing Dr zarko Argo you're
playing Dr zarkov
and you're like [__] hey I'll never
die and then one day you [__] die it
ain't fair oh
I guess that's why I gotta appreciate
people
um while they're here absolutely and you
gotta appreciate every moment man every
moment passes you don't get it back and
we tend to forget that like
it all ends Memento Mori
kids something they used to put on
Settlers Graves uh it means remember you
must die that's how we should begin and
end every show [__] Jeff's kiss should
be Memento Mori
and it's not meant to be like crimson
and [__] it's meant to remind you that
like
this ain't no day is promised and
[__] tomorrow may not happen so
[__]
remember you must die and then sometimes
I think uh I tend to forget that all the
time but oh yeah it's gonna all stop
isn't it I just think it's gonna go on
and on I think I'm gonna I think year
after year I'm just gonna continue to be
ignored by the academy until one day
but I think uh yeah I gotta remember all
the time that it [__] all comes to a
close doesn't it I just remember that
from the title of an X-Files episode
yeah Mento Mori was the episode that's
right it was Scully was looking for her
the the origin story behind her dad's
death
I believe that is um that's some deep
Cuts right there ain't nobody talking
about the X-Files but us kids you tuned
in to [__] watch him talk about
Ant-Man
take a back seat to our discussions
about the X-Files season five episode
three Memento is your favorite what's
your favorite X-Files episode one of
mine is hands down Clive Clyde ruckman's
final Repose
I still talk about like you know when he
Peter Boyle who is so wonderful in it
plays this guy who could like see how
people are gonna die and he's he's
talking to Mulder and and you know Fox
mull is like well how do I die and he
goes well I'm not going to tell you he's
going but
All I'm gonna say is audio autoerotica
asphyxiation is a really [__] sad way
to go it's funny because like part of
Mulder's storyline was he loved
pornography yep
um and then even better than that is
like he's trying to tell Scully and
scully's like I don't want to hear it
and then finally she turns around she's
like all right how do I die and Peter
Boyle goes you don't
it was such a [__] awesome moment
it means like she she never dies she'll
never get older she never dies she's in
raccoon 4 man
she's a Brimley
um I love that one I loved um
pusher
if you remember that one it was a guy
who could push thoughts into other
people's minds yeah um I thought that
was freakish as [__] and then beyond the
sea where scully's Dad dies but first
they're visiting her and then her her
dad and her mom and then they leave and
then she's fall asleep watching TV and
she wakes up and she sees her father
sitting in the chair across her and
she's like confused she's like oh my God
you guys came back and he's just going
like
he's talking but you can't hear him and
[__] and then the phone rings and she
goes to answer it and she turns around
and he's not there anymore and they tell
him like dad just died and stuff
um and that's where they go see Brad
Dourif remember he plays that guy in
jail where he's like spontaneous
combustion no no no that's the one where
he's the guy who he's the killer who he
says like at one point he calls her
Starbuck and [__] and he's saying that
Dad is in him as well
um he's the not Monty Props Monty Props
is the guy I don't think they ever did
an episode with him but remember in the
first episode of X-Files you know she's
like they're like are you familiar with
Fox Mulder and she's like yeah he's the
one that wrote the Biograph on Monty
Props that got him killed the profile on
Monty Props that got him captured he was
a serial killer they should [__] do
that man maybe they did maybe I missed
that episode but like
I like talking about it makes me want to
re-watch it
but that's a lot of [__] X-Files like
there was like 11 seasons and what was
the one that where oh um
oh Jose Chung's from outer space was
that what it was with uh Tribeca
and Ventura yeah Jesse The Body as Men
In Black that was a great episode too uh
that was the one with um
like like where they're telling the
story and and the one guy like the one
cop in the town has a real mouth and and
like dirty mouth and he he flat out says
he goes what the bleep is bleeping going
on
um all right you know what [__]
enough of this [__] should we sell some
[__] yeah hey kids you know we got a
sponsor and it's a wonderful sponsor
because this sponsor has been with us
the whole the whole ride the whole the
like family as they say in those movies
that I don't watch
um which I saw a trailer for Fast X and
I was like
it seems like they got their own thing
going on
yeah they figured out their own thing
um it was weird it was like it's it's so
strange to be somebody who spends so
much time
enmeshed with pop culture but like those
movies
I've I've completely missed those movies
all of them so as I was watching this
Trail and they're like ride or die man
like one last ride what is this meant to
be the last one
uh I think there's two more I think
there's fast X and then there's whatever
the last one is going to be called last
11 yes
fast to Heaven what do I know they seem
to be doing very well
um you know who's doing very well kids
tell us Folks at native
nativedeo.com here do me a favor why
don't you go to nativedeo.com
Fatman right now to follow along because
you could use the promo code
fat man at checkout you can get a sweet
20 off your first order man that's
nativedeo.com
Batman or use that promo code Fatman a
checkout you get 20 of your first order
but if you're like wait what is native
well let me tell you native they make
they make amazing deodorants just
amazing deodorants as well as other
things man but like the deodorant like
they make skin wash and hair wash and
skin wash is that a thing body wash I
guess so
laughs
they have a candy
kit going on right now
um they've got this Limited Edition
Candy Shop collection
um featuring gummy bears you want to
smell like gummy bears under your
armpits like you can smell like gummy
bears there well a you could stick one
there but that's gross or you can use
the native Deo version of it they got
strawberry and vanilla Taffy
who don't like taffy unless you're you
know [__] from the modern day and age
yes this is for people to actually know
what Taffy is we were born in the oh my
Taffy they got sour Berry belt
um which I've uh I've smelled the sour
Berry belt I put some of that on the
other day yeah did you feel I was
followed by a thousand bees it was uh it
was good I smelled like candy people
were just like who's eating sour belly
sour berries not me because I wasn't I
wasn't lying yeah my pits are eating it
yeah eating it right up stopped me from
[__] sweating and [__] you know
native for their aluminum or aluminum if
you're in the UK a free deodorant native
keeps their ingredients list bare naked
kids
just that we like it with ingredients
you understand like coconut oil we all
get that shea butter we all understand
that and baking soda we all I don't know
what what is baking soda normally used
for do you what do you think do they put
it in bread is that what I will say that
uh tip the first word of baking soda is
what baking soda is used for Oh I
thought you said the tip like I was like
that's also that uh Native deodorant
check that's a rise yes
two hour odor protection naturally
derived ingredients and a smooth
residue-free application man that's how
you want it in life you want it smooth
and residue free native also offers a
variety of scents with new and limited
edition scents being released all the
time uh when you use native you will
smell amazing all day long thanks to
their long lasting scents man they got
better than Common Sense Uncommon Sense
want to smell spicy and woodsy sweet or
clean and fresh well native has a scent
option for everyone now is the time to
make the switch from an antiperspirant
ugh just sounds so horrible to natives
that sounds way better when you visit
their site you can discover all these
fresh scents and maybe even try out one
of their body washes while you're at it
that's what they call it not skin water
skin wash is something like a [__]
serial killer uses to treat the [__]
hides of people he strips off their
bones and [__] he's like you like to
bleach your largest organ let me be with
this skin wash natives like can you
please not talk about serial killers
I love native uh it's it's my deodorant
that's what I use and for years I didn't
use deodorant until we started doing
spots for Native and I was like well
can't [__] sell it unless I know if
it works start using it man I love the
[__] uh candy cane I love the
gingerbread cookie I love you know they
just do sense that makes sense
sense that makes sense there it is
uh what do you what are you [__]
doing watching this show when you can be
over at nativedeo.com
fat man and using the promo code Fatman
a checkout to get a sweet
20 off your first order man that's
native d e o dot com the
lettersdeno.com Fatman or use the promo
code Fatman to check out for 20 20 off
your first order uh that's native
deo.com kids and we thank good Folks at
native
for sponsoring the show probably the
last one after I [__] jumped in with
like serial killers love this [__]
if native hasn't abandoned us yet though
I don't think they ever will they also I
believe make a lavender as well oh see
there you go lavender very common kids
weed used to be calming but now I got
this I traded weed for a little bottle
of [__] Bulgarian lavender what's my
problem
just do do lines of it off a stripper's
ass yeah
[Laughter]
there it is uh all right we're done
selling [__]
uh now we should uh talk about some
stuff future Maya Futurama yeah says I
brush my teeth with baking soda can you
do that is that thing I guess they put
that in toothpaste right like arm and
ham or baking soda and they make an Arm
and Hammer [__] toothpaste did you
know that Heinz made peanut butter
why
that's what I thought but I was at a
place where they [__] gave me like
single peanut butter cup that you spread
he opened up and it was from Heinz and I
was like they make peanut butter as well
I mean maybe they got the whole
miniaturization Tech down so this is
what do you need in a cup whatever the
[__] you want in the cup yeah so I
believe it says
whatever the [__] you want in a cup
I mean I ain't telling them to like stay
in your [__] Lane do ketchup like
they can do whatever they want but like
do you ever hear of Heinz doing peanut
butter
no and I would have thought the ketchup
would have been a lucrative enough
business to be like we'll just be the
only people who give anybody ketchup
gotta be yeah I mean the you know other
people
you got the Hunts Brothers coming in
there and be like well what if we
smashed a tomato what about us what if
it was cats up yeah
um go [__] yourself
could you imagine like your Heinz and
you've like really conquered the [__]
condiment market and then you're like oh
by the way let's also do peanut butter
as it seems greedy
that's what I'm saying man that's why
Heinz don't sponsor this show because
we're always coming down on them always
[Music]
seriously [__] with eyes
uh Guillaume LaBelle and chat said Heinz
Gruber
I like a little I'm 52 years old so I
like a punny word play every once in a
while
um
Walter he said Bic makes pens razors and
lighters fair enough I guess everyone's
allowed to make whatever the [__] they
want
I guess
you know I suppose the show just [__]
do you write it yeah as we all just
existentially wrestle with I guess we
all should be allowed to make whatever
the [__] we yeah like what are we
[__] doing here I guess we do more
than one thing we do this you know we do
[__] shows that we write and [__]
yeah look Heinz is like [__] you you
spent a lot of plates we're in peanut
butter yeah listen we just do
thicker [__] fluids and [__] and we
we do spreads
if you can spread it we [__] do it
leave us alone
jinx2501 said Heinz Kang sup
uh there's a good segue and we're back
just to uh Ant-Man and and the WASP
colon quantumania uh Mark sod already
and talked about on the last show and if
I remember correctly boy did he love it
I was a huge fan
um but I finally caught up with Ant-Man
and the WASP yes how did you feel I'm
not going to say spoilers because it's a
review so I saw somebody in check going
like don't [__] say spoilers I won't
anything you want just [__] love me
um the movie opened 19 weeks ago
I honestly I I've I've I was kind of in
a bad place yesterday so I was like you
know what we'll put me in a good place
going to see a good old Marvel movie in
the theaters and uh did it help I will
say this
what put me in a good place was I was I
was in a I went to see it at City Walk
and
when I left the theater I happen to
notice like there was a seating capacity
written on the door 86 and there were
those like seats so movie theaters are
getting [__] smaller it's mod castle
like the main theater is 230 seats then
it's like the next one Down's like 175
150 120 and our smallest theater is like
98 or something or maybe 102. it's it's
so crazy
um
less less seats makes no sense to me but
I guess their ideas like well if it's
comfier seat
you'll get people to come out uh Mike
it's also that and because I remember
when I when I went to go see Godzilla
versus Kong at CityWalk and we rented a
theater and so it was like me and three
other people rented a theater go see
guys over his con there was like 20
seats in that in that box they were all
reclining seats which is great but it
was like listen if a movie's not making
a bunch of money but we still wouldn't
have it in the theater
who's coming out to see it 80 people
gonna come probably not are 20 people
gonna come maybe so they just they just
begin to to shrink them even further and
further and further I think their
biggest house is like 300 but then you
get down to the the tiny matchbook
I was like hey it's you and six other
people enjoy it's I look as a guy who
owns a movie theater as a guy who is an
exhibitor so much so that I get to go to
[__]
cinemacon at the end of April where I'm
gonna see the [__] Flash before any
of yours
before you before [__] silly ass bamf
man for any of the people in this
audience I get to see flash I me [__]
theater owner Kev Smith member of NATO
National Association of theater owners
um that's uh that that's that's
I I'm gonna go there's a panels it's
just kind of like Comic Con as well so I
got panels one of the panels that I want
to go to is one about food
um you know because that's a big part of
the [__] film exhibition exhibition
business you don't really make money
showing movies that's for damn sure
um so I'm curious how others do it
we got uh we're very close to securing
our liquor license
that we can open a bar in the theater
and [__] serve drinks and [__]
um but yeah I'm you know look I love
[__] Spa Castle Cinemas and [__] me
and my friends bought it a few months
ago as I've said Ad nauseam but
this is the worst time to [__] own a
movie theater like the opening night of
Creed Three
seven o'clock show we had like six
people
but meanwhile for clerks open all night
packed house son
um and also mind you we didn't charge no
Creed 3 price of 10 bucks that's what
costs to see a movie it's my castle 10
bucks unless you're military then it's
seven bucks
um but uh
you know when we do events like like
events where I'm gonna be there we got
guests and whatnot
like it was I think the clerks open all
night was 37 bucks a ticket 37 and 69 if
you bought a blanket like we you know
because everyone was sleeping over more
or less
um that's my secret to surviving in
movie exhibition I just charge way more
but uh I went to see it in 86 uh seat
theater you know with the [__] lie
down seats and whatnot and I'm gonna be
honest like I can't give you a complete
review because I was exhausted and I
fell asleep I really have to stop
falling asleep while watching movies in
a movie I've become such an old man
but the most delightful part of it and
it turned my frown upside down
and uh took care of my blues for a
minute or twos was there were kids in
there
like and when I say kids I don't mean
like [__] four-year-olds and sure
they sound like they were like nine to
11 in that range
Who Loved Modoc
and every time Modoc was on the screen
they were [__] laughing hysterical
not in derision mind you not going like
what like just they were delighted by
the Modoc character storyline
everything they were just it was all
smiles and laughter from those kids and
then after when the lights came up
all they talked about as they walked out
was Modoc they're like oh man remember
when he said like you don't always have
to be a dick or whatever and I was like
did he I must have slept through that I
was like Grandpa was napping
um yeah man Modoc uh was Corey stole it
was it was pretty good I know some
people were mad that it wasn't like the
real Modoc origin but I thought it was
kind of cool the way they brought him
back and made a Modoc and made sense uh
the movie itself
what can I say
um I liked it I mean I know we're not
meant to compare these things and stuff
but like it's not my least favorite
Marvel movie
um and when I say least favorite uh you
know there's I I feel like man I don't
want to get in trouble for this but I
feel like eternals was a tougher sit for
me than Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania
but that being said it didn't feel
I like the first two it didn't have the
same kind of charm as the first two
um the quantum realm or as we 70s kids
call it the microverse
just because they don't have the [__]
rights to say that anymore it don't mean
it ain't the microverse
um was you know creative as [__]
allowed for like you know Dreamscapes
and [__] like that
uh
but um
I don't know I I I I feel like we
probably would have fared better if
everything took place on on Earth I mean
I guess technically the quantum realm is
on Earth but in our world more so than
than that world
um but uh you know
what was my ultimate take on it
the utterly washable pain reading it
certainly knows how to direct a movie
it's not like oh this guy he don't know
[__]
um he you know he he did it he directed
he directed it better than I ever could
have
but um it you know and and I think the
girl Cassie was was good although
she had one line that she just said over
and over and over
do you know what line that is
um you have to save people Dad no but no
you're close
God run
it was a [__] they should open that
[__] on Father's Day she said dad so
much
um it felt like Hope was barely in it
like I know you know spoilers at the end
she shows up and [__] saves his ass
um
but uh
you know and Michelle Pfeiffer had a lot
of [__] screen time that's for sure
yeah as did the Aging Michael Douglas
who just like got a laugh out of me when
he was like I love ants thank you
clearly okay
um Michael Douglas that movie is is
watchable for me and I will watch it
again particularly to see the [__] I
fell asleep during because
um Jonathan Majors is so [__] good
I'll watch him acting anything man like
and he was it felt like he was in a
completely different movie performance
wise
like he was bringing it
um you know I'm not saying like Paul
Rudd didn't bring it he was playing it
you know [__] Scott Lang want man and
stuff but like Jonathan Majors can't
phone it in at least not at this point
in his career
um
he's [__] riveting to watch so I I
was I was there for him uh I know there
was a Theory online that Creed Three is
like he's a Kang [__] variant or
something like that
and when I watched that I [__]
watched it through the prison it was
like it could work at one point I was
watching Creed Three and I was like oh
there's killmonger oh there's Valkyrie
oh there's Kang like
see him see you again yeah it's just a
Multiverse event there's just five
actors in this business and they all
make
all the movies at this point
um I I liked Modoc like I thought it was
uh kind of kooky and well done
um
and uh but you know hated to see him go
but
you know I was there for his Arc
um
it just it didn't feel I kind of agree
with Mark though it's like Kang felt
like the wrong [__] villain for this
uh he has nothing to do with Scott Lang
no and no and and it's also like
you know Thanos was introduced to us
through drips and drabs and post scenes
throughout those movies and we didn't
get a full [__] Thanos movie until
what Infinity War
yeah so it felt a little weird to be
like well here's your Kang movie like
you know way in advance
like because you know there's a whole
last movie coming called the Kang
Dynasty and we also know he's going to
be in secret Wars
so I you know I didn't understand why
they would why they didn't drip and drab
them in you know I know some people are
like he was in Loki you [__] yes I
know that
um but a version of him was introduced
in Loki he who remains uh it just it
felt like he was way too big and bad for
Ant-Man which I guess was part of the
story right like because he kept saying
you're way out of your league Ant-Man
yeah
and then Ant-Man proved somehow that
he's not out of his League
but um I you know I I might have done it
a little differently I might have saved
Kang
you know put a little bit of him in
there in a post scene or whatever but do
you think that was always the plan to
make king the big bad in Ant-Man or you
think that came later on
I mean I think it was it was the plan
for a while because I mean they cast
Jonathan Majors pretties
long ago like early in the in the
conversations about it they knew the
majors was going to be in it but it's a
point like they did nothing but setup
fan
is this setting up Thanos I mean a
[__] Avengers is setting up Thanos
like you're just you're you're getting
some of the story so that by the time
you actually see Thanos it's it means
something and you kind of understand
you've met his daughters who all have
like various and opposing views about
what their father is and what their
father means and
and I just I kept on not being able to
get a read on what Kang wants other than
to escape and to conquer
um and what does power set is like what
can can do yeah it felt like he had the
all the abilities of the of the [__]
Rings like uh you know of uh sharing
cheese Rings yeah but it's like what a
ring did I fall asleep did they mention
anything about like oh I made those
Rings no
abilities and [__] because yeah all of a
sudden he was like he could push Scott
against things and turn his daughter
upside down which I was like well I mean
I guess that look if that happened in
the real world I'd be like yeah that is
pretty impressive but [__] Thanos
could just
obliterate a [__] even without a
goddamn Stone in his hands or something
like that
uh but Kang was a little bit a little
bit uh you know or his power is science
based or Magic based or yeah like
because you always have the feeling that
when he was on the planet with with
Janet
he was like just a guy who's charismatic
and helping to convince introduce this
that whatever but he needed her to help
him fix slash get this powered Globe so
that he
hours machine but that didn't seem to be
a thing that gave him powers or not and
then he still doesn't have the power
glow all over the quantum realm and has
weird-ass handy glowy things is it the
armor that gives him that like what
red comet and chat says it's future
science based so there you go
glad they explained yeah I can't wait
till we get to the Future and have some
of that science
everybody's just turning people upside
down and [__] like that
yeah and it's also the like
Multiverse or are we doing time travel
because those are not actually the same
thing
and yes I know that the [__] Quantum
realm is how Scott Lang decided that
they can figure out how to time travel
but
anyway I've had my say about Kang
[Music]
um somebody said somebody had a good
point I'm gonna bring up
uh Gabriel Matthews in chat says
watching a series of movies where Kang
gets defeated over and over is only
going to tell the audience that he is
weak over and over he doesn't feel like
a big bad but like a bunch of minions
you agree with that
I mean I just don't see why you have to
defeat him over and over like I I really
I said I really thought that [__]
from the trailer I thought [__] Scott
Lang was I thought Ant-Man was going to
die
you know there's would continue to
conquer there's there's a there's a big
part of me that thinks that that ending
was a reshoot that there's a version of
that that's like oh yeah no he's he and
either he's stuck in the quantum realm
oh he and hope are stuck in the quantum
realm and then that's how the movie
ended and they they test it to an
audience they're like oh no this is too
depressing we can't just leave Scott
down there so he's got to come back he
said okay
I think you're I think you're right
Lloyd Sharma says in chat there is no
consequence in this movie it would have
been good to see one of the big
characters die Ant-Man or at least hope
should have died I'm with you GC is
asking where's Scott Moser and Walt
Flanagan are they supposed to be in that
movie
Scott I just talked to Scott I talked to
all the time Walter's in New Jersey I
don't understand that question what does
that have to do with Kang and Ant-Man
I'm lost or did he think that they were
going to be on this podcast yeah I was
like what it was very strange
um
yeah I I I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm curious
what what they had shot because I know
they re-shot
like something you know not too long
before the movie came out that ending I
think because they had him back at a at
a
Baskin Robbins somebody saw them
shooting and they did me so maybe that
second Baskin Robbins bit at the end
right where he's like you're Bug Man
um
DK Daniel says the last movie ended with
him stuck in the quantum Realm
yeah because that's where he is at the
start of yeah that's right that's right
yeah oh my God I forgot in the PS scene
because that's when everybody else got
dusted and then he came out in what in
endgame or Infinity war end game
end game
yeah it's been game because remember in
the [__] trailers God
I just I'm not one of these cats it's
like Marvel's better [__] get back
get it together and [__] but
everything was just slow pulling Taffy
building up to like Thanos and infinity
War
and you know remember like [__]
getting so anticipatory when they showed
like those early trailers for end game
where he's like you know it's me it's
Scott Lang I I I I'm Ant-Man we've we
fought in Germany
and you know black widows or Captain
America is like when is this from and
she's like is you know it's happening
right now or whatever
it's just there's they they need to get
back to that kind of Storytelling where
you build that guy into a major big bad
as opposed to go like look at him look
how big and bad he is and then he gets
like spoilers the guy gets killed and I
know it's like yeah well it's just one
version of Kang and there's many
and I yeah I don't I'm not saying like
no audience can follow this multiversal
Tale But
having a villain that could get killed
over and over and over
and I thought the big threat of Kang was
that the one we were going to meet is
the one that has killed every other king
like that it was going to be the baddest
Kang Kang the [__] conqueror there
was he who should not be named there was
the Disco Kang there was all these other
kings but there's the [__] big one
that they had to Exile into the quantum
Zone because he was so awful that he was
going to kill everybody else and that's
the Kang we're following if that's the
case great but it can't be crunch all
you want we'll make more kangs because
then who gives a [__]
yeah yeah it's it's you know I don't
know
and also like the thing that I remember
uh the the build up to end game was that
it was less I mean Thanos was a big part
of that but it was also we had been
following Tony Stark for 10 15 years
we've been following Steve Rogers within
15 years so when Tony had the Line This
is the end this is the end of the road
that I brought us to
you know it's like oh [__] you're right
like we've been watching this
personality shift we've been watching
this development for this much time and
I'm not invested in anybody really that
introduced in the last two phases
you know and when they do re-engage with
the sort of Legacy characters with Thor
Ant-Man it's
it's just not quite Landing in the same
way that it had before now this is
this movie
um is I mean it's made far more money
than Oliver make in my lifetime but it's
not making the money it's supposed to I
guess is the complaint I mean I think
it's making more than any Ant-Man movie
has made before it no that's not true it
opened bigger than any ant movie you
know movie open for it but this one is
actually going to make less I read
than its previous two incarnations
that's why everyone's writing all these
think pieces and they're like what the
[__] is Marvel gonna do and stuff
um I don't know I bet you Banff man
could look that up
so we're not just sitting here like a
couple dicks just saying [__]
um but I think I think the big complaint
is like it ain't even gonna do the
business that Ant-Man 2 did they spent
more to make it it did open bigger than
the other two but has dropped by 70 in
its second week and it keeps going
down cocaine bear took it out and [__]
um well I mean it's it's at let's see
currently it's at 198 million dollars
worldwide or just here
lifetime total so that's worldwide
actually noise that's domestic that's
just domestic it's domestic
um I think last I heard struggling to
get to 500. and
I don't know uh Rat GE tv says this was
the Kang that supposedly killed the
version of The Avengers yeah like
because he was like are you are you an
Avenger did I kill you before
um that's the king they should have left
alive and maybe he's not dead he just
got taken away by ants did you ever see
him [__] die did he explode or
whatever the [__]
I don't know but like that's the king I
would have kept around if he's meant to
be like the Conqueror the one that like
you said was like the worst Kang in the
Multiverse so much so that they
stuck them in the quantum realm aka the
microverse Brian Christian chat says
maybe that wasn't the main Kang the
Conqueror I guess there could be another
one
I suppose anything's possible but
um yeah you're good you're a chill says
me he'll come back as the beyonder you
think that's the case
I mean it's it's a
beyonder because I don't know if you
just want to introduce a [__] dude
who's like I'm the beyonder
um yeah I wonder what the original
ending was I wonder if like Scott died
they killed that man that would have
made it [__] Epic Man if they had to
like if they were like let's kill off
Ant-Man at the end of the Ant-Man movie
yeah got his kid ready to go right she's
ready to be the young Avenger mm-hmm I
mean maybe that's what they're that's
the long game is setting
Avengers
that Kang Mark Kirkman says that gang is
still alive and is the threat the
Council of Kang's just banished him
because they will not kill a king right
but I mean didn't at the end of Ant-Man
and the wasp quantumania
I thought the ants
[__] took out Kang like first they
had the whole family ready to fight Kang
together and then [__] Incredibles
looking shot but then all of a sudden
Michael Douglas shows up with his killer
ants and they took
they took Kang out that's that's what I
saw but it doesn't necessarily
mean
that uh
you know he's he's dead that version of
him all in the game says it's at less
than 450 million worldwide Ant-Man did
519 million worldwide and Ant-Man 2 or
Ant-Man and the WASP did 623 million
worldwide so it does look like this
one's going to be the lowest grosser
I mean he needs another like 60 million
dollars Global to match the first movie
which you know I don't know if that's
possible or not it you know given how
that's the most tapping the returns have
been in subsequent weeks that's a that's
a long ask I don't know if it's open
everywhere yet
uh it's not Out Of Reach but you know
you expect for increased returns not
diminishing returns yeah that's the idea
this was supposed to be the biggest one
rotary dial in chat says the
post-credits scene says it all Loki
season 2 will be Mega
yeah so what
I don't know I don't why will it be Mega
no being another king
well I mean it's yeah I don't know
I get it that everyone keeps going the
Council of Kings can't kill a king
that's fine I didn't say they should
[__] kill him I'm just asking was he
killed at the End by those ants like
Dunlow says thought Ant-Man was going to
go from the goofy joke hero to a serious
self-sacrifice give my life to save
everyone here but then they clicked the
button and he was back
yeah that would have been dope man if he
like
if they let him like [__] sacrifice
himself at the end so it had some sort
of Arc like that
didn't Kang get sucked into the infinite
possibility realm well he'll be down
there for who knows how long fighting
infinite versions of himself is that
was that in the movie I didn't notice
that what I saw was a bunch of ants like
took Kang out
Ken got sucked your impression
he got sucked into the machine
the cat this King and Ant-Man is from
the future from Kang Dynasty I think he
was defeated and ended up in the quantum
Realm
huh
what
why isn't Mark Telling Kev that Kang and
Scott fought after the ants took him
away
did they
all right Scott and him fought
well Scott was big and he was like gang
and he was breaking buildings and [__]
and Kang made a [__] energy bubble
that
was protecting him and [__] but then
I just remember like Scott well Ant-Man
the wasp and and
ant girl or whatever they're calling
Cassie
um we're ready to show down and that's
when like the army of ants showed up
uh Drew Bob wrote in caps so this must
be important he was sucked into a
wormhole after getting knocked into the
core
hmm
okay
fair enough I I remember so little of it
because so little of this movie stuck
with me that at this point anything that
anybody tells me happened in that movie
might have happened in that movie
uh Giovanni says you need to watch the
movie again dude oh I will I [__]
watch all these movies over and over
again I will never watch this
Birds to save Scott says why see the
champion is sucked into some other place
Kang will return
um well obviously can we return but will
this
Kang return
beige Wonder says you all are completely
overthinking this you're absolutely
right but the show is fat man beyond
that's what we do here is overthink this
stuff what do you got Banff man I was
I haven't seen Ant-Man yet uh I've been
scared Away by what everybody else
thinks of it
but if it's this hard I mean this isn't
a Christopher Nolan ending right like
we're not watching Inception like the
fact that we have 2 000 people in chat
and no two people can agree with how
this movie ends may be part of the
problem
agreed now I have some people telling me
that they fist fought
like and I remember them fist fighting
that's where he's like I don't have to
die or I don't have to win you just have
to lose or whatever the [__] and he
busted his helmet and [__]
uh Cassie's Mark Williams says Cassie's
superhero name is stature not Aunt girl
did they say that in the movie
I don't believe so but again you didn't
say ant girl but I mean don't come at me
like you know hey man a stature if they
didn't say that in the movie I'm not
gonna know that because
I believe Cassie being a part of the ant
family is relatively new in the comics
or at least new compared to when I was
reading comics on a regular basis
yeah that fight happens after the ants
so the ants come in and take [__]
Kang down and then
Kang got sucked into a wormhole and
appeared in a movie that ain't right I'm
looking for real answers here
stature is her name in the comics yeah
in the comics all right so
David said they didn't say in the movie
I mean I did fall asleep through a lot
of it so
Kevin how do you remember it ended says
Morgan Rangel
um I what I remember this is my version
the ant family was like standing up
about to stand up to him and then
[__]
Michael Douglas showed up with an army
advance
and then they took Kang down and then
Cassie no it was uh there's a fist fight
in that chamber where the [__] portal
is which is the last time you see him
it's post ants because I remember and
that's post dance and I remember Kang
like Jonathan Majors was [__]
desperate to get to that hole and even
that I was like that's a believable
performance man oh yeah he wants that
hole he wants to get to that hole
um and you know Ant-Man was stopping him
from doing it and [__] like that but I
like I did I I I'm again like I think
Jonathan Majors is a wonderful actor
because
I even believed that he wanted to get
the [__] out of that theater
he was going for that hole and he was
like oh [__] this is my only chance the
thing I've dreamed about the whole
[__] movie so I guess yes they fought
each other
but then
Scott
wasp shows up and pulls him through the
[__] hole
[Music]
yeah I don't know
yeah uh you know
to JC's point it should not be this
difficult to describe the ending of a
superhero movie and now that you'll be
here movies can't be complex but
it should ultimately be an emotional
resolution and there is no emotional
resolution at the end of this movie like
everything everywhere all at once is a
superhero movie it is the hardest
[__] movie to describe to anybody but
I can tell you exactly what happens at
the end of that movie because it is not
about Multiverse it's not about body
hopping it's not about [__] and
everything bagel it's a mother trying to
explain to her daughter that she has
[__] up most of her life but the only
good thing that's ever been a part of it
is a little bit of time that they get to
spend together
and like okay again I see how that
resolves I understand what that is but
like
none of the emotional tableaus of any
character in this movie gets a
resolution in that final scene it's
fight fight fight
I've come to save you great the guy gets
sucked into the whatever and we're back
on Earth as if nothing ever happened
Zach Webb and chat says Kang got drug
off by the ants then once Ant-Man and
hope feel safe Kang shows back up and
fights them at the end and at the end of
the fight he gets sucked into the
Wormhole the end
okay sure
this Kang from quantumania is the same
one we'll see in Avengers Kang Dynasty
except he defeated he's defeated and
banished to the quantum realm all right
so we're going to see Kang the Conqueror
in Kang Dynasty the same Kang
who probably didn't die it looks like he
got sucked into a [__] thing he got
sucked off at the end there you go
but I don't remember who in chat
mentioned but it is a weird choice to
have the guy supposed to be your big bad
beaten by the weakest superhero in the
Marvel Universe
Sebastian
and a hero said Ken came back without
his superpower since the ants damaged
his suit I remember that like at one
point his [__] wrist was going so he
had to fight Scott just as a guy kicking
another guy's ass which like [__] again
Jonathan Majors against [__] Paul
Rudd right yeah like Jonathan Majors uh
almost beat up [__] Michael B Jordan
so Paul Rudd was going to be no problem
whatsoever there's a great bit I think
it was Paul Rudd was on like Fallon or
something and he was talking about it's
like well you know who's going to win in
a fight between Kang and forget Scott
Lang he's like well I'm going to show
you these two men's health covers one of
which is Jonathan majors and it's him
[__] jacked to within an inch of his
life shirt off just everything that
could Ripple his Rippling it's like and
then here's me and it's just [__]
Paul Rudd wearing a t-shirt and jeans
he's like they don't ask me to take my
shirt off I'm just a guy he's a [__]
Adonis and I'm just a dude wearing
[__] a gap
true tan and balma chat says Kang was
sucked off into the battery that he
needed for his time ship that battery
was theoretically powered comprised of
the ten Rings how is that what
is that was that a thing
they never once mentioned the ten rings
and as far as we know Xiang Chi has the
10 Rings yeah I mean last time we saw
that movie uh the ten Rings he he got
control of him right yeah I mean unless
there's a rings are us where you can
just [__] pick up some metaphysical
rings in the quantum realm why see the
champ says Kang's Powers came from his
futuristic Tech Kang and Scott fight as
Kang is about to skill kill Scott hope
returns blasting him and he sucked into
the battery powering the time engine
yeah that part I remember like she came
in and [__] pulled Scott out and I
guess she shot some [__] at Kang and
blew him into the battery but that don't
mean he's dead
no
although I don't know how it do time
battery but whatever bing bing and shot
goes but honestly what did Kang do wrong
Kang was right yes
um
Cali's in 132 says stop making up the
story it was a bad film well we're just
trying to figure out what happened
um allegedly Danvers says allegedly the
ten Rings kamala's bangle and Kang's
Tech are all part of the same technology
foreign
said Scott says in the closing ADR that
he isn't sure if he's really dead or not
yeah that part I get so let's just go
with that Kang didn't die
but he did get beaten by Ant-Man which
seems a little
we've spent
ending of this movie then Costner spends
at the end of JFK figuring out who the
[__] killed JFK like
Daniel goes you remember it you thought
ants killed him I'll be honest I thought
my ending was way cool the aunt struck
him away
left
Tomb Raider said did we touch on how
Kang vaporized people by touching them
but didn't try to do it one single time
to Scott
and the end and flow grown says the end
credits show him still alive do they
no they showed
a thousand other kings yeah they showed
three other kangs then they at the very
very end they showed a old-timey earth
king that [__] Loki and Owen Wilson
were like wow
well
um
Kang's Tyler Hall says uh Kang's a
cockroach always another one plus
someone has to be he who remains
oh I get that there are a lot of
different Kings
but
Dwayne Vogel says lame beaten by the
third weakest Avenger
who's the other two weaker Adventures
then Skyline
we did see which is another Hawkeye fan
and black widow I suppose but then again
he came and went he came to explain for
the other weaker Avengers than Scott
langwar oh
I didn't did I fall asleep on that part
god I don't remember anything anymore
you'd imagine now that I'm not smoking
weed that I'd remember everything but
[Laughter]
um
okay Morgan Rangel says Kevin he wasn't
defeated by Ant-Man he was tripped up by
him there's a difference excellent point
one is actually worse okay yeah Morgan
Rangel to sit there and watch movies
with me all the time so he can explain
[__] he didn't get beaten he slipped on
a banana peel that left on the ground
and fell into a Time Tunnel
Welcome Back Cotter theme song uh Tana
Robinson says Welcome Back Cotter theme
song greater than this movie
can why I see the champ says can kick
the crap out of everyone until Modoc and
the Ants overwhelmed him damaging his
Tech when he fought Scott it was hand to
hand and he beat Scott's ass he did
all right wow I mean we may have spent
more time talking about this movie than
the movie actually the running time of
the movie
and a lot of people don't believe in the
10 Rings Theory because they were like
that it was never once mentioned go
ahead Batman we should discuss esoteric
ends to every Marvel movie we've went up
like three 400 viewers so let's just
keep doing it
keep more people are watching they're
like yeah same discussion Bros hey
they're trying to make sense of King
come on
hey kids look at Kevin they're they're
on to something he's getting
um
Seattle KO said sober cab is evidently
more forgetful than THC Kevin yeah I
can't explain that Anthony M says Creed
3 isn't as confusing let's talk about
that what a great segue thank you and we
shall
um
uh we all saw Creed Three Batman get in
here for this
you have feelings and thoughts yeah you
must right Banff
um
I uh you know
it's not like it was like geez what's
gonna happen but I enjoyed the [__] out
of this movie once again
I'll watch Jonathan Majors [__] do
anything like I thought he was riveting
in this [__] movie as well not just
physically riveting like watching him
climb those ropes with two [__] bare
hands and [__] at one point you're in
his training but like his whole
character that was the one thing I was
disappointed in about Creed 3 was they
gave away too much in the trailer
because like in the beginning like I
wouldn't have seen what was coming if it
just showed up and [__] and was like hey
man I'm your old friend and [__] like I
wouldn't have known
that he was coming for it all except in
the trailer he literally said I'm coming
for it all it's one of the moments where
I was like man like
why why do they give so much away I mean
I guess that's how they get people in
the theater and how would you you can't
you got to show the third Act of them
fighting and stuff
but I enjoyed the hell out of it I
thought it was uh well done Michael B
Jordan can direct like nobody's business
man most
actors who move to directing do a really
great job I find because
you've sat behind so many directors over
the course of your career Michael B
Jordan been acting since he was a kid on
The Wire
you aggregate a style like you know you
sit there going well I would do that I
wouldn't do that if I was in charges but
I do so by the time they jump in there
like aflac's perfect example got sat
behind a lot of [__] directors
including a lousy one like me and then
by the time he was ready to make Gone
Baby Gone
a dude's like
fighting like a ninja man like he's got
[__] extra sensory powers and then by
the time you get to Argo [__] yeah the
Clint Eastwood track it's the like I've
been sitting behind Masters for most of
my career and I've been asking questions
and paying attention what lenses this
watch do this so when they get the
chance they've they've been to film
School
um this was the they it's funny how like
you know the first two Creeds Rocky's a
part of it and this one Rocky's not a
part of it all but they do reference the
Rocky fight like when they're talking
about
who is Jonathan Major's character giving
him his chance they talk about like you
know nonsense Apollo Apollo gave a
little unknown guy a shot at the title
and stuff and every time they said I was
in theater like they're
thank you
um yeah I enjoyed that [__] movie
although I
forgot most of Creed 2 because when the
big Russian shows up and starts sparring
with him I was like why is this a thing
and then it was like
they fought in the last one did they
like what happened at the end of the
last one he just beat Drago and that was
it or they just [__] hug it out or
something because
um he's he's beating the [__] out of
Drago and his father Ivan Drago throws
in the towel
to save his son from dying in the ring
um and it was a whole thing where like
if if the young Drago was named my fur
game I can't remember if he beats you
know adona's Creed it'll be this
Redemption story for their the entire
Drogo family because in Rocky IV when
[__] Drago loses it it brings shame
to the drug ornate and his wife won't
talk to him anymore but Gene Nielsen
like he's living in the [__] like he
was the pride of Russia who then loses
this fight and becomes this [__] bum
and his son was his one chance of
redemption but he had to let his son
finish the fight and so he's got to
choose do I save my son's life or do I
let him keep getting the [__] kicked out
of him and bring more shame to the Drago
name and he chooses to save his son's
life
um in boxing are you allowed to do this
[__] yeah yeah yeah it's not against the
rules that was new for me when he
Jonathan Majors kept doing this [__] I
was like loud you're allowed to do that
in boxing I mean what it does is it
exposes your midsection like most people
don't do that because then you've got
both arms up here and all of this is
wide open that guy could expose all of
that and it wouldn't [__] matter
because it's just I mean to borrow a
phrase from Rick and Morty come gutters
oh my God that guy is [__] ripped and
[__] but yeah that was the one thing I
was watching going like is it are you
allowed to do this in boxing but I guess
you could do it yeah because most boxing
defensive stances are like this so that
your elbows can still be covering your
rib cage while then protecting your head
but this is just
yeah whatever
um the only place where I missed Rocky
though was at uh
uh spoilers if you haven't seen Creed
Three the funeral scene like you would
have imagined Rocky Balboa would have
showed up for
the wife's the wife of his best friend
who they must have known each other and
stuff that was the only place where I
was like or even at the fight like Rocky
didn't show up at the big fight and
stuff in Dodger Stadium somebody in chat
said they didn't like the CG Stadium I
didn't mind it and one of my favorite
parts of that whole third Act was when
it's just them when the stadium goes
empty and they're just fighting and you
can't hear a pin drop and [__] like I
thought that was a cool idea I didn't
like the the when they brought in the
jail bars and stuff that felt a little
you could have I felt like a hat on a
hat it felt like emptying the stadium to
just have those two fighting was pretty
dramatic and I was like that's cool
that's a really cool idea
it's very I mean and Michael B Jordan
has been talking about this this entire
press circuit is he's a huge anime fan
and so that like the feeling of here we
are on this big busy thing and then we
just we drop everything out just to
focus on these two these two characters
and then it gets very impressionistic
and very almost like [__] film Noir
and German it's his cabinet of Dr
Caligari with his giant bars reaching to
the heavens and
and uh and yeah like I I it's a it's a
it's a very well directed movie he knows
what he's doing you know he knows you
know how to assemble a scene he knows
how to shoot action all invite stuff
it's great
um I just I was not Creed the first
Creed is one of my favorite movies
and it it shattered me when I first saw
it like I was just in tears by the end
and a couple times in that movie I was
just I was a wreck because it it is very
much about you know Adonis Creed you
know or Adonis Johnson you know trying
to earn what he feels is unattainable
which is worth which is do I deserve to
be here why didn't anybody want me you
know he's been fighting his entire life
to prove that he's worthy of his last
name and so by the time you get to the
end of that movie and by the time you
know you see [__] the the quick flash
of Carl Weathers is Apollo looking at
him by the time you hear that [__]
music you know you're in the bag for it
you know Rocky 2 is a little I'm sorry
Creed 2 is a little bit less emotional
but like yeah like Donna still wants a
thing he's still trying to prove a thing
he's still you know there's still
something to fight for but by the time
you get to this movie like there's
nothing left for him to want
and so by the time you get to the end of
this movie I was not really emotionally
invested in what was happening like yeah
okay it's I guess it's good for him to
beat this old guy you know who had taken
the fall for him as a kid and now came
back and wanted everything that he had
but didn't really try to take anything
like it's
it's just it's muddy emotionally by the
time you get to the end and so I'm like
no I appreciate everything that that
Michael bought to it and you know yes I
will watch [__] Jonathan Mages do
anything
but by the end of that movie I was not
moved
um emotionally in any real way
um and by the end of the movie I was
like well clearly you know it's like you
can bring this in for a landing and of
course Adonis is going to win
um I like that they hugged it out at the
end so to speak like I don't know if I
believed it because Dame was pretty
pretty mad most of the movie and then by
the end he's like well apparently you
did learn some things that I didn't
teach you but I I liked it rather than
it just being a narrative about like you
know these [__] hate each other and
[__] like that they fought and that's
got out of their system and yeah but
what was really beautiful was the deaf
representation like the storyline with
his kid was Pitch [__] perfect
um I thought that was I thought that was
so sweet like and all and also that she
was into [__] boxing and he was like
it's not about violence it's about
timing and and something else and like
being observant and [__]
um but I did like that last fight and
now that you say it was put through an
anime prism that's that makes it kind of
cool [__] loved like when he [__]
gut punched him in the sweat like came
off yeah oh that [__] was they have they
done that before ever not in a Rocky
movie but that's very anime that's very
like you know big climactic [__]
Dragon Ball Z fight they would do that
kind of [__] all the time
um I kept on wondering I you know when
they cash out their Majors like oh he's
[__] clever lags kid right he's gonna
be [__] baby clever Lang that's what
I thought and I thought I'd heard that
like when they first talked about it
like that he was going to be the young
Clubber Lang or baby Clubber Lang but
apparently not apparently not but I kept
on like the more I watched them I'm like
oh well see then there's
there's a really interesting story about
two sons of famous fighters whose lives
went two completely different ways you
know but you know they ended up in a
[__] home because what happens to
clubber we don't know what happens a
club you can make that whole [__] up we
know what happens to Apollo you know we
know that these are two guys who are
trying to earn back the legacy of their
fathers but one ended up in jail and one
ended up in [__] Bel Air and now
they're reconnecting on the other side
and then you get the idea of oh your
life was supposed to be mine in every
way because my dad was also a
heavyweight champion in the world but
got [__] beat up by that white guy
like my Dad should have left me
everything but he ended up a [__]
whatever he lost it all gambling
whatever that was he died penniless and
broke it's like you supposed to have I'm
supposed to have what your life is and
now I want it as opposed to the weird
like
kind of subjective like oh well you just
did well for yourself I wanted to be a
boxer too so I was a golden gloves and
now you're a boxer and that sucks
everyone in shot is talking about uh
Dragon Ball Z that was a Dragon Ball Z
punch where the [__] you hit somebody
in the Smoke comes off the back mark C
in chat said then making up at the end
was okay with me because it felt like
Dame realized he didn't just get given
his life his winning shows that Adonis
deserved and worked for it yeah yeah I
buy that absolutely
um
well put yeah yeah so wait do you do
they do another Creed
well they're now launching a Creed verse
coming out of retirement again well I
know they had a they had a Drago movie
that was in development about the Drago
kid
um I think they have plans to do
something with his daughter who is
clearly training to be a boxer
um they're talking about a rocky origin
story although I'm pretty sure Rocky one
was an origin story so I don't know what
what origin there is like oh when he was
a [__] Lake breaker for the mob okay
I suppose
um but yeah MGM is very much about like
given the success of Creed 3 and given
the investment that Michael B has with
it like we want to build it out into its
own Suite of movies and TV shows
Creed
yeah because he's a huge anime yeah so
I'm down with that
um if they do one more Creed then they
should like do the clever Lang story I
think that'd be cool
yeah I mean because after a while it's
like yes I understand that it's you know
we'll
we saw them do with Drago how many times
you're gonna go back to the old Rocky
movie well for bad guys or the same
token it's what we're here for guys
very true man what'd you think about
Creed Three
Creed one I watched Creed on the plane
the first one on the plane on the way to
Austin and I still I've seen it 20 times
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time uh and I did I got like teary eyed
like four different times watching that
movie
um and I didn't
care like I didn't care emotionally
about anything in Creed Three
the way that I did in Creed one or Creed
2.
and I think it really missed
like one of the things that's so great
about Rocky is that like even in Rocky 5
that everybody hates
that's the one where he gives the speech
to his son that is so mimified where
it's like nobody's gonna hit you as hard
as life like it's not about how hard you
get
it's not about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you get hit and keep
going forward
that's in like the worst of the Rocky
movies and I felt like this movie didn't
have that
big moment it didn't have kind of that
Rocky four moment where he gives the
speech at the end which
for the time that movie came out was
like when the you know
Soviets were like the biggest bad guys
on Earth and Sylvester Stallone is
cheesy and whatever as it is it's like
saying like hey can't we all just get
along
um
so I think I really missed that I really
missed like is there an opportunity to
like spend more time with like
Adonis and his daughter and he gives his
daughter that speech it's not just like
the one sentence it's like more of a
crescendo I think I would have liked to
see
uh more
Jonathan Majors on Muscle Beach Montage
like that could have been really cool
and I feel like it was truncated a lot
um I just didn't
I I thought it was really well directed
for a first-time director I was amazed
but like emotionally it was I think it
was the most stagnant of mid of all the
Creed movies
oh my God you're [__] you're the new
Mark Bernardin [__] with your little
honestly I thought they had a really
interesting opportunity because I think
to your point JC that what made the
Rocky movies great when they were great
is that Rocky lost more than he won
you know and so there's always a hill
for him to climb whether that hill was
in the ring or whether the hills out of
the ring but then they had an
opportunity and they they kind of
glanced up against it talking about
mental health in the black community
which you know I'm not going to say is
non-existent but it's definitely not
encouraged
um historically for men to talk about
their feelings to talk about their how
they're broken and to try to do the work
to put themselves back together
you know and so the idea that that
Adonis still carries all of the trauma
of growing up without a dad or thinking
that he was abandoned of trying to prove
his worth of now having a kid who you
know so much of Rocky 2 is about him not
being able I'm sorry Creed 2 was about
him struggling with engaging with it
with a deaf child and what that means to
have a to have a kid with a disability
you know all of that stuff is is
Weighing on him and now comes this this
again an old trauma you know the guy who
went to prison in his Stead you know to
have the real breakdown and to have the
real putting himself back together like
I know you got to have a [__]
running up a hill
but you know the real montage is that
guy learning to get in touch with
himself that is actually a champion that
he's kind of pushed to the side and
kicked to the curb for most of his life
you know and it it was one of a couple
of things that felt interesting but
never explored in that movie like I kept
on expecting [__] Dame to make a run
at Tessa Thompson
because like he's connecting with her
he's like the way is wonderful in the
movie as well she's she's great until
she has nothing really to do yeah you
know when she because it gets
interesting when he's like well what
does it feel like to watch somebody else
sing your songs
and she's like well I don't know like I
just had to make a choice that my
hearing was losing and I had to how much
time do I have left being able to hear
and do I push it by singing and
Performing even though I know it's not
right do I try to still make music and
I'm compromising on what I thought was
my gift like that's a real connection
point for both of them like how much
time do I have I'm 35 years old I just
come out of prison I want to be Champion
I've been watching my life slip away you
know and then there's a guy who seems to
not understand what he has in front of
him like that's that's a club
relationship hey woman you know how to
handle that shot like why don't you come
over here have a real man like
I just I wanted more of him engaging
like breaking apart adonis's life Brick
by Brick like I took away your Champion
I [__] with your your big fight I'm
taking away your money I got your girl I
convinced your your kid to start
fighting in school like I blew up your
whole [__] spot and now I have this
belt what are you gonna do
and there's a great opportunity there to
give Tessa Thompson the speech that
brings him back that rallies him that
gets him through the end fight that she
never gets
like she you know I understand why
somebody in chat was like without
Stallone none of it works and I I don't
believe that yeah
I like Stallone in those movies but I
think this movie worked and you know
even without Stallone in it but like
give tessitation Mark anywhere right it
was missing a bit of emotion go ahead
get give her that moment let her be the
inspiration now that gets him up when he
doesn't think he can stand up
um it doesn't need to be Sly anymore but
you didn't
do any of like you didn't give us that
um it made me want to watch Rocky 3
again
you should have never came back
hey woman hey woman I wanna I wanna do
the voice so bad but I don't think I'm
allowed anymore when we were kids we
could all do [__] Club online but now
I feel like I'd get clipped and memed
and destroyed on the internet for trying
to do a version of color line but it's
Kevin Smith doing Mr T cultural
appropriation of the worst kind but it
uh I love that [__] scene Mr T is so
[__] unbelievably great in that movie
like his screen did I think he was in DC
cab before that maybe maybe it was a car
wash it's it's one of those like weird
early 80s relics but like that's his big
[__] move it's Rocky three one of the
best movie villains of all time so great
he's so antagonistic uh well I see the
champion chat said Creed 3 is a
straightforward streamline feature that
delivers exactly what it's selling the
film is an utterly predictable tale told
extremely competently and you love it
for its directness
that reads like a [__] legit review
right there yeah like and I I would have
no problem with Creed Three and I don't
really because again it was to have a
huge problem with if there hadn't been a
Creed one like if I hadn't known how
good it could be then I wouldn't be that
upset with how kind of just right up the
middle Creed 3 is
uh will Wilkins said Creed 3 is the
anti-antman
we all know what happened at the end of
that
yeah did they actually leave the stadium
or let's just get into it is is Dane
dead yeah the whole time he's a phantom
uh ghost day says it's not missing
Stallone as the actor it's missing him
as a filmmaker he puts all those things
that are missing in the movie The
Emotional Drive is always present in his
Rocky movies
um yeah I mean I don't think It suffers
for lack of
Stallone's touch but
he's right in all those Rocky movies you
know remember her in Rocky 2 where she's
in the hospital and she's like win Rocky
win
and he's like why don't we for him I can
still do
him so
March you can't do Mickey but I can do
Mickey so yeah it goes both ways for me
welcome to my black privilege the one
thing I can do
three totally watchable flick you're if
you're into boxing movies totally check
it out and I think I think the kid did
such a great job kid I mean he's man now
but uh Michael B Jordan did a [__]
great job directing it
um but Jonathan Majors [__]
[__] that dude gives like his
performance in Lovecraft country is
different than his performance as Kang
is different than his performance as
Dane like this guy's like a legit
wonderful actor yeah I really want to
see magazine Dreams the movie what is
that yeah I heard about it in Austin for
the when we were there for the awards
ceremony somebody was like a magazine
dream is gonna be huge what is it about
um he plays a bodybuilder
um I don't I don't is it the story like
of the like
is it based on a true story I don't know
I I know so little about it and I think
they're keeping it kind of close to the
best because it went to Sundance and won
a bunch of stuff got picked up out of
Sundance by by Fox Searchlight I think
but but apparently he's great and it's
it's also a physical transformation
movie it's while I'm in this good of
shape while I look this way and then and
can maintain it I'm gonna take my shirt
off as much as I [__] can and so I
think he's playing a bodybuilder who
wants to be better but whatever whatever
and I'm not entirely sure but [__] it
again we'll watch that dude do anything
he was an Army commercial uh when I went
to go see uh um kylo Ren hits dinosaurs
today and he was just like I'm [__]
look Jonathan may just talking about how
cool the Army is which whatever but like
you're good in this commercial
the um
we interviewed them at Sundance Jonathan
majors and uh the director of the
magazine dreams movie and it struck me
as uh
tonally like the wrestler the Mickey
Rourke Wrestler movie but instead of
somebody at the end of their career it's
somebody kind of more towards the
beginning but is obsessed with
uh the celebrity of it
sounded really interesting
I'm in dude's got incredible [__]
range
um
somebody said something here Saul Good
said Lovecraft country came out same
time as the latest Terminator movie and
I remember thinking man they could have
had him as the newest Terminator what a
Miss is that true they were going to
maybe cast him as a Terminator
that I don't know I I sort of feel like
that's a complete waste of his talent
because he's gonna say like [__] this
guy's got incredible range like don't he
don't need to play a robot I think a
man's robot
robot
um
I'm gonna hit 65 real quick yeah let's
hear it Mark saw 65 Kids Adam Driver
versus dinosaurs with lasers kylo Ren
hits Dennis right now playing its mod
Castle Cinemas if you want to go see it
um it is it's a it's a fine down the
middle old school kind of
Creature Feature science fiction movie
like it's and it's also a bit of Lone
Wolf and Cub and that you know Adam
Driver plays a a guy with a with a
terminally ill kid who takes this
two-year mission to get enough money to
pay for a kid's treatment
in the middle of the mission [__] goes
wrong hit by an asteroid field and crash
lands on dot dot dot Earth in 65 Million
BC and so in order for him to escape
this planet and rescue the girl who's in
the the only other Survivor this
accident he's going to Traverse the Wild
and do battle with [__] dinosaurs
um as such you know exactly what this
movie is going to be it's a couple of
jump scares it's a couple of survivaly
things it's a couple of uh dislocated my
shoulder and a weird not as I was
encroaching will I get my gun fast
enough yes he will
um
but you know it's [__] Adam Driver
who's like a very good actor yeah
there's another guy with [__] range
put him and Jonathan majors in a movie
together hell yeah reading the [__]
phone book and you'll get you'll get
something worth watching man two of them
are incredible actors yeah I mean he's
he's much better than this movie is but
this movie is just it's right down the
middle
um
This was
uh tsg and
um Braun I think which is
um
Matthew Vaughn's company
um yeah like it's
and it was it was written and directed
by the guys who wrote a quiet place
and so it has a lot of that kind of very
Elemental kind of like here's a here's a
here's a problem we're gonna make our
character solve here's some difficulties
we're gonna give him and also oh yeah by
the way there's monsters hiding in the
[__] Forest
um so yeah like it's I it does not
reinvent anything it is not an antidote
to sliced bread
um but if you want to spend like you
know an hour and 45 minutes in the the
foresty Wilderness while Adam Driver and
a little girl attempt to survive
dinosaur attacks go for it
some would be put that quote on a poster
it's all good corrected me just by
saying it was just a dream casting for
the role of Terminator it's not he'd
heard that Stephen Bruce says Kevin I
just want to let you know that this is
the best I've ever seen you look why
thank you Stephen Brew
means the world Stephen Brew wants to
get to like second base he wants to get
pushed in the hole
that Quantum hole
um now have you are you caught up on
Mando Kevin now I have not watched uh uh
the second episode I saw episode one but
I haven't seen the second one yet
what we could do here's what I'll
suggest
um
let's see
my kid I'm we've been doing this for two
hours and I'm supposed to go eat with my
kids so what I suggest is we hold our
news
that we were gonna do today for Friday's
show okay
um Friday in case you come in late kids
you're like what do you mean Friday's
show uh me and Mark will be doing fat
man beyond live from smodcast Castle
Cinemas in Atlantic Highlands as we
bring the Ides of Mark Festival to a
close man Mark's coming out and we're
showing three 80s classic 80s movies
Dune is on Wednesday night go get
tickets right now it's
mycastlecinemas.com or ceasemont.com
Streets of Fire is on Thursday night
tickets available at cspod.com or
smodcast tocinemas.com then Flash
Gordon's on Friday night and then after
Flash Gordon we're doing fat man beyond
for the very first time from Smart
Castle Cinemas for the very first time
on the East Coast together
um so that episode is where Mark will
talk about the last
of us is that what it's called indeed
um the season finale and uh
uh we'll do all the news that we're not
doing here yeah and we can do Mendo
episodes two and three because we'll
have three out then I will have seen yes
oh that's when is it why when's the new
one drop Wednesday I think oh perfect
all right so then we'll do Mando two and
three and then we'll be doing Q a as
well but we'll take in the questions
from people in the audience that time
right
um so yes Friday night kids we're gonna
do this again
this is just a little taste this is just
a tease
[__] showing a little nipple that's
all
did you see that I was almost whipping
my title I know what the [__] man
Stephen Brew said that I looked good and
I was like maybe I looked showing nipple
good yeah put them on a glass
that's what Friday's show is gonna be
all about putting them on the glass kids
uh so if you're not in the New Jersey
area New York New Jersey Pennsylvania
area if you're not on the East Coast
um you'll be able to watch Batman Beyond
as we stream it right from Spa Castle
Cinemas but if you're on the East Coast
well why the hell wouldn't you be in the
room where it happens the room where it
happens to borrow a phrase from a
[__] Broadway popular New York area
Entertainment yes
um yeah man it's gonna be all sorts of
Good Times uh and we haven't done it
with an audience in a minute when was
the last time we did with an audience to
at uh coming villain August of last year
maybe
bamf yeah it'll be more responsibility
shows coming up though as well kids uh
for in fact we should book one soon uh
after the odds of Mark I come back on
back to Los Angeles on September 18th
Mark is going to be doing a signing
at Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash on
Saturday the 18th which costs nothing
[__] free for nothing
Jumping On a Plane he's going to be uh
signing whatever you want but he's
signing primarily uh Adora in the
distance
um so put that on your calendar Saturday
uh March 18th Mark Bernardin at Jane
Silent Bob's secret stash right there in
Red Bank New Jersey I will be on a plane
to get back to Los Angeles to do
Hollywood Babylon with Ralph at Flappers
tickets at cspod.com but then I'm back
in Los Angeles for like two weeks during
which time we should probably try to do
a Cantina show yep um we can try are you
going away are you staying back East for
a minute
um no I'm I'm I'm I'm on a plane that
night on the 18th I'm here for all of
the week of the 20th the 24th and then
I'm in New Orleans for the uh Overlook
Film Festival I'm bringing Splinter to
New Orleans
oh and that's the other thing we should
probably tease just a little bit yeah we
may or may not be showing splinter
after the fat man Beyond podcast sounds
like a Yes sounds like a distinct
possibility kids what are you waiting
for don't sleep on this [__] don't you
sleep on fat man beyond live from
[__] smart Castle Cinemas on Friday
because it sounds like you may get a
splinter a splinter or the whole damn
thing you can't see it online he ain't
gonna stream it online so like if you're
like oh will we see it no you're gonna
have to see it live in person but wait
let's go back to New Orleans so you're
showing it at a festival there the
Overlook Film Festival which is uh they
build themselves as the greatest horror
film festival in the country
um and so yeah very excited our second
our second Film Festival appearance
um folks and look at that folks you can
see it [__] you could either see it in
New Orleans New Orleans as they say
locally or
you might be able to see splinter in New
Jersey out of real ass movie theater
owned by a real ass Movie Maker Kevin
Smith's my castle Cinemas and stuff uh
Jack and Chad is asking uh JC do you
sell food at the Cantina [__] yeah you
do we do very good food yeah they do
markers
devouring last two weeks ago I was I
bombed in I I played [__] trivia at
the Cantina
did pretty well for a person who doesn't
study
uh Jay Graham is saying Kevin any chance
you'll sell online tickets to watch some
of the special q and A's at this mod
Castle live you don't even have to buy a
ticket to watch fat man beyond
you can watch it Friday night it's gonna
be happening right there some mod Castle
Cinemas
um the uh we also got coming up I think
it's March 31st
uh Brian Quinn is bringing in practical
jokers the movie
to Smart Castle Cinemas and uh we're
going to show that and chit chat
afterwards and stuff
um I don't know if we're streaming that
or not but I'll find out uh but yeah I
honestly like if we stream stuff I don't
know that we'll charge for it like I
think we'll just kind of put it up on
the YouTube channel and stuff because it
acts the free commercial for the for the
theater at the very least but we're not
gonna [__] show Splinter that's not
gonna happen you got to be live in the
room yes we will cut the fat man feed
and then show whoever's in the house a
short
if
if you guys are not on the East Coast
this weekend however
we are opening early on Friday the 17th
for St Patrick's Day you can
uh you can come get some green beer and
pretend you're Irish with us but
banshees of inner Sharon
but more exciting than that is every the
weekend after St Patrick's Day so
Saturday March 18th
uh we celebrate sir Patrick's Day Sir
Patrick Stewart's day so uh cheap green
beer to celebrate uh Sir Patrick we're
gonna do Patrick Stewart trivia
and uh a bunch of X-Men and um
and Star Trek drinks to celebrate you
know the geek icon Patrick Stewart and
before we uh even started the show you
were talking about you're on the Star
trek.com website for what was that we
are we are doing on March 24th which is
super exciting we're doing an official
Star Trek strange new worlds event which
is uh we're going to be doing trivia
with cast from the show
um this is a flyer from the Star Trek
website which is so exciting
uh prizes presented by Paramount that
shit's official Yeah official official
official
star trek.com
um
so we'll be doing that on March 24th on
Friday it is uh open to the public so
you can come in and and hobnob with uh
real Star Trek people and tester Star
Trek knowledge we have the
uh Chateau Picard wine that we will be
serving so if you ever wondered what
Jean-Luc Picard's wine tasted like we've
got a case of that we'll be serving and
it looks like we have the official
Romulan ale that we will have as well
it's banned in the Federation but you
can get it at scum and villainy cantina
uh so really cool uh
Star Trek stuff coming up as well
whether you're into treks or Wars uh the
scum and villainy cantina is the place
for you man scum and villainy cantina
right there in Hollywood in the heart of
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard you are
you open seven nights a week seven
nights a week and then we open at 11 A.M
uh for lunch on Saturday Sunday Black
Belt Jones and chat said the grilled
cheese at the Cantina is awesome
awesome he said do you uh if you're
casting about JC for Star Trek trivia
questions one of them could be what uh
what podcast do you may or may not know
and love
um is now officially a member of the
crew of the USS Titan on Picard
and that would be me I'm I'm was name
checked as Ensign Bernardin
on episode 4 of Star Trek the card wow
look at you man yeah the [__] PA
calls for me to report to the deflector
control room
I was like huh
down the show correct I worked on season
two I didn't I had no part of season
three other than apparently now I'm I'm
enlisted in Starfleet you are man you're
a member of starfully you're part of the
continuity and [__] absolutely do you
have a page on the Star Trek Wikipedia
like the Star Trek version of Wikipedia
somebody needs to create that somebody
needs to put that in there internet you
guys do you guys want one of our
um our sir Patrick's Day
trivia questions we'll see if you can
get it yeah let's go let me hear one all
right so I'm gonna get I'm gonna read
you a line of dialogue and you need to
say whether it's Professor Xavier or
Jean-Luc Picard oh this is fun I might
be able to pull this off go ahead buried
deep within you beneath all the years of
pain and anger there is something that
has never been nurtured the potential to
make yourself a better man
Picard that is that's that's Xavier
talking about Logan
that is Jean-Luc Picard
are you kidding me isn't that wild that
is wild man so I've got a bunch of stuff
like that to make you win the trivia are
there prizes or no there will be try
prizes for
um
for
sir Patrick's Day trivia will be bar
credit and then uh paramounts bring in
the cool stuff for the 24th for that
Star Trek trivia
look at that man all right so there you
go come to the scum and villainy cantina
kids
and get your [__] serve Pat stew on
[Music]
um eating that [__] serpat stew uh
what is his date on that
uh sir Patrick's Day is uh on March 18th
this year and the strange new world
event is strange new worlds sorry event
is on Friday March 24th
and don't forget uh this week is the
Ides of Mark right out here in uh well
not here in New Jersey uh at smog Castle
Cinemas Mark showing you uh Dune David
Lynch is doing on Wednesday night
streets my name is a killing word that's
right man more deep my name is a killing
word uh Streets of Fire on Thursday
night
and Flash Gordon on Friday night
followed by the debut of fat man beyond
right there at uh smodcast Castle
Cinemas and then Saturday in the
afternoon I think it starts at noon or
11. Mark is going to be at Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash 20 years in
business as a brick and mortar kids I
will sign whatever you put in front of
me you pull your [__] dick in front
of Mark he'll tag it and [__] yeah yeah
I mean you need to pull it I won't hold
it yeah he ain't gonna touch your dick
that'd be weird but he'll sign it I'll
show you that [__] uh
uh and it'll be back in Los Angeles here
uh uh March 18th for Hollywood Babylon
at Flappers comedy club with Ralph
Carmen somebody asked in chat they're
like do you live in Jersey or Los
Angeles uh the answer is both
with with a bof both I live in both uh
so I'm splitting I'm now because of the
theater I spent a lot of time in Jersey
obviously so we're splitting time
between both Coast kids so I'm doing a
show here doing a show there for for
years for about 20 years straight it was
all shows in Los Angeles and people on
the East Coast were like what about us
well
now I'm doing shows there and doing
shows here man by Coastal and buy kids
because it's hip
[__] trendy to be by so I'm
bi-coastal and I'm bringing my bio
Coastal buddy Mark Bernardin
for the odds of Mark that's Montego
Cinemas and then to do a big old signing
at Jay and Silent Bob secret stash what
do you think come out and visit
uh tickets available at csmod.com or
Flappers comedy club or just show up to
scum and villainy cantina you ain't got
to buy no tickets and stuff you do got
to buy some drinks is there like a drink
minimum it's coming villainy bamf man JC
bamf uh no you can come in and buy a
single
root beer and sit there all night
just hang out get your geek on for those
of you who can't be at the scum of
villainy Cantina or can't be it's
modcastle Cinemas uh don't forget we're
streaming fat man beyond on on uh Friday
night
uh during that episode Mark's going to
review the end of the season finale of
Last of Us we'll talk about
mandalorians episodes two and three
because three will be up uh by that
point
and uh we'll do all the news that we
didn't do here and if you're in the room
as soon as the credits roll on fat man
beyond well [__] we're gonna give you a
splinter right in your dick
that's kind of Splinter best planner to
get dick Splinter the private eye
show that Mark and I will be doing next
yo have you watched any of Poker Face
not yet how is it I hear it's wonderful
procedural it's like Colombo it's very
Colombo so Colombo in fact that when you
get to the end of watching Poker Face on
peacock you know how it you know it'll
always cue another program to come up
next
what comes next after Poker Face is
episode one season one of Colombo
is that right yeah which which was a
really interesting watch because the
first episode of Colombo ever was
written by Stephen bochko
and directed by a young lad named Steven
Spielberg what yeah
he'll go far you know he's got a future
I think
um kids have you enjoyed yourselves well
if you did it's because of these two
guys man give it up for Banff man
uh and give it up for The Man Without
whom there is no fat man beyond you'd
imagine it's me but no I'd be doing
anything else you know me I [__]
always trying to be in your face and
[__] smear my brand all over the
corporate landscape the only reason
there's a fat man beyond is because good
old Mark Bernardin is the only one with
the balls to actually tell you what he
thinks about Ant-Man and Creed
going out on a limb
uh there it is don't forget Friday we're
doing this again man if you're sitting
there going what [__] Friday no
that's when I go out and drink well may
I suggest you sit in and drink and watch
us do this [__] wonderful show where
we're to talk about all the culture that
pops right here on fat man beyond Man
tickets for all that other [__] happened
in New Jersey cspod.com kids don't
forget hopefully we'll see you there man
we need some help on the Streets of Fire
I'll be honest with you
has been the toughest cell man I keep
chalking it up to a Thursday night but
you got to convince people so that's why
I keep saying it stars the Snyder versus
Martha Kent
which is either a draw or a warning
uh there it is my friends uh there's
your fat man beyond there's your [__]
fat man beyond for tonight uh for fat
man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark
Bernard tune in next time kids same fat
Time same fat channels modcast.com or
youtube.com Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss
everybody
[Music]
yeah
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the
AKA ask Kevin every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and Silent
Bob get old off Kevin Smith
[Music]